this aggressive critique of every
inherited idea
will destroy us first to misery and then
to weakness and then to dictatorship
[Music]
hello and welcome to martial matters
with me Winston Marshall for The
Spectator in London today I have the
pleasure of being joined by Dr yoram
hezoni author of the books The Virtue of
nationalism the Jewish State the
struggle for Israel's soul and his most
recent book conservatism rediscovery Dr
hezoni is also the chairman of the
Edmund Burke Foundation president of the
herzl Institute and leader of the
national conservative movement which
only last month enjoyed its conference
Dr hazoni thank you so much for speaking
with me today my pleasure thank you for
making the time for me Wednesday I
wondered if we could start with some
perhaps semantics or some basic
questions
and your most recent book conservatism a
rediscovery really gets into the
political philosophy of conservatism and
there's some things I don't fully grasp
but I wondered maybe if I could ask a
very simple question
what is conservatism
well conservatism is a is a political
standpoint
that sees the the center of Politics as
being the uh the conservation and
transmission
uh and strengthening of uh the nation
through time over generations and I
think it's uh it's it's appropriate
today to contrast it with liberalism
because the the two things have been
somewhat confused
um a liberal is someone who begins in a
different place begins with saying look
the heart of politics is the uh the
freedom and equality of the individual
and uh the the the role of government
and the role of politics is to secure
individual liberties and and and
equalities now of course uh it's
possible for a conservative and most
conservatives are concerned among other
things with uh with individual liberty
uh but because conservatism begins with
uh with it begins with the collective it
begins with the nation and says what
Have We inherited what are our
Traditions what are our interests uh the
interests of our nation what do we need
to do in order to make it stronger that
means that a conservatives is always
going to be balancing and trading off uh
in in areas in which liberals simply you
know very often simply assert well look
individual liberty is at stake here and
therefore we already have our answer and
in your book you describe it as let's
say uh conservative nationalism as as a
Unity of different tribes making a pact
together to to work cohesively in the
first half of the book I I couldn't help
but think where's the role for the
individual in this collection the tribe
in the second half of the book I felt
that your definition of conservatism
seemed to incorporate liberalism it
seemed to incorporate the values of John
Stuart Mill John Locke uh the the the
the the the freedom of of the individual
so I couldn't quite uh couldn't quite
separate conservatism and liberalism in
my head maybe you can clarify that sure
well look it's very important to uh to
recognize that conservatism
is going to be different from one one
nation One National tradition to another
um what whatever is uh an appropriate
conservatism in Britain is not is it's
simply not going to be the same as an
appropriate conservatism in uh in India
or or or in Russia or or somewhere else
um in this conservatism is very
different from both liberalism and
Marxism which are Universalist theories
and claim to give you the answer about
what every country in the world at all
times in history should be like uh so so
that uh it's it's certainly the case
that uh that an anglo-american
conservatism uh is is going to include a
strong strong elements of uh of
individual liberty pick up in Praise of
the laws of England by the the the great
um common lawyer and and jurist and
political theorist John fortiscu this is
a book that was written in 1470 It Was
Written in the Middle Ages and the first
thing that Fortescue starts to tell you
about is uh the separation of powers and
the the checks and balances between the
king and the Parliament and the relay
relationship between a private property
and individual liberty and yes he says
why is it that all across Europe people
say that in England we're the freest
we're the freest people in Europe and he
starts to explain how the common law
constructs individual liberty for
example by forbidding the king to uh to
enter a property without the permission
even even you know a a a farm a farmer's
Home is not is not something the king is
allowed to enter without his permission
much less to take something all right
and and by the way many of these
elements that you know that we find
already in in medieval uh English
political tradition many of them go go
all the way back to the Bible and
there's often explicitly connect
connected to the Bible so the most
important parts of liberalism certainly
do do exist
within the common law tradition within
the conservative tradition uh in Britain
and America however we can see the clear
clash
in the triumph over the after the fall
of the Berlin Wall for 30 years
International a liberal internationalism
became kind of the uh the dominant
ideology of you know of of both labor
and tories both Democrats and
Republicans and this was mostly true
across Europe
and um and what you see in this liberal
internationalism is a uh is liberalism
Unbound from any kind of conservatism
liberalism in uh in almost you could say
in in kind of a a pure sense in which
the freedom of the individual
uh to establish a corporation to uh to
take take his or her company and you
know move the factories to China without
any concern for uh what effect that has
on on on the workers in Britain or in
America we we got to see 30 years of
pure liberalism I think the brexit and
the Trump movement and in general the
the the return of a a nation-centered
conservatism uh is a clear rejection of
uh the idea that you can simply take the
freedom of the individual and turn that
into everything in politics sorry to I
don't want to stall you in but just back
to definitions because you talked about
pure liberalism and also the liberal
world view and you mentioned was Mark
swellview which is easier to sort of
understand it's that there's different
classes of people there's an oppressor
and a press and there's a power Dynamic
with between them but where what is the
liberal worldview how would you define
that let's take John Locke the axioms in
the second trees of government the
premises on which he explicitly bases
all of his political Theory number one
all human beings are perfectly free and
perfectly equal that that's the
Cornerstone number two moral and
political obligation only comes into
existence where you've consented in
other words if if I didn't agree to uh
to be bound by
um by your claims in one way or another
if I didn't agree to it then then I'm
not bound I don't have any obligations
and number three uh he says the purpose
of government is only to pursue and
establish these
um uh equalities and Liberties which
which all all rational people he
believes will come to that now this is
an extremely simplistic and shallow in
my view a form of thinking about
politics it didn't really emerge
Victorious as kind of like the uh the
ultimate answer to all questions in
politics until after World War II but as
this liberalism has uh has advanced over
the the the last couple of hundred years
um the uh the job of conservatives has
been to uh to attempt somehow to uh
prevent extremely abstract concepts of
uh the perfectly free and perfectly
equal individual from taking over every
aspect of society so let's take an
example
um in in a traditional any kind of
traditional conservative politics would
would recognize that they're different
nations and they have different laws and
the the the the national government has
a responsibility to maintain in general
the the good and the interests of the
people who the government represents and
and so a question like you know what
right do uh you know hundreds of
thousands of foreigners have to enter
the country this year
for for a conservative
it's obvious that it depends on whether
having hundreds of thousands of
foreigners entering the country is going
to benefit and strengthen uh your people
uh it cannot economically but also also
in terms of culture and and and the the
cohesion of the of the society that
that's obvious to to conservatives but a
liberal says we'll hold on a second
um we we believe that all individuals
are perfectly free and perfectly equal
so what right do I as let's say an
Englishman what right do I have to to
tell someone who's uh coming from from
Nigeria or or from from uh uh Poland or
anywhere else no you're not allowed to
enter this country you think it'll be
better for you but I'm going to stop you
and I I think that you see this uh that
that you see this easily this this this
hesitation uh among uh British Elites
American Elites certainly in the
European Union where you know we're
we're eliminating borders is kind of
like an explicit aim of the entire EU
Enterprise what's what's going on here
what's going on here is fundamentally uh
the liberal assumption that a foreigner
is is just as good as you are and
therefore you know you have no right to
prevent them them from entering the
country so I I think that's a very very
uh Clear Point on which Liberals are on
one side and conservatives are on
another not necessarily just as good
because I think itself would say an
immigrant is just as good it's not a
moral judgment right as much as saying
that they are they have an equal right
to the Latin is that what you mean sure
but but you know a a conservative uh who
who sees someone crossing the border
illegally will say look you're a
criminal you if you violated the laws of
this country and I think quite a few
liberals at this point they're uneasy
with that you know what right do we have
to you know if if the laws are unjust
and maybe it's just unjust to tell all
these people they're not allowed to
enter the country whether there is such
a thing as as a nation whether it exists
in history whether people belonging to
one nation actually should treat one
another in in a different way from the
way that they treat people from from
other other nations this is this is the
heart of politics today
is there a danger that without that
liberal offset it can go too far the
obvious example being that let's say
1930s Germany we all know how it ended
there was a union of the different
tribes except one tribe was not just
excluded but we know how we know how the
story there and and so the conservatism
needs that liberal uh
dialectic to keep it from going too far
in another Direction
I I think you're right let me just say
something about some something about
1930s Germany because that example is
um it looms so large in uh in the public
imagination if you read mineconf and I
do not recommend reading Minecraft but
but if you read it you'll see that uh
that uh Hitler never says
um my ideology is biological imperialism
my he does say that Germany should be
the Lord of all the earth and the
Mistress of the globe so I mean he
expresses the desire for Germany to take
over the entire world but he calls that
nationalism and uh so we have a
um we have a semantic we have a semantic
problem this is a jingoistic nationalism
in many parts of the world even today
the word nationalism you know I I I'm
from Israel and I'm going in a few weeks
to India and places like India and
Israel the word nationalism is a
positive word it's not not a negative
word but when when it's used as a
positive term most decent people use the
term to mean
um uh a world of independent nations
it's a it's a principle it's not a
Utopia necessarily but nationalism is a
is a principle that says that in general
we're better off if the world is
governed as uh many independent nations
rather than uh one nation attempting to
create a a a world Empire it's
nation-statism might be a less
triggering word for British or America
it could be the problem with
um here people say to me why do you use
the word nationalism why can't you say
use patriotism George Orwell for example
uh argued for that and the problem is
since we are talking about semantics
first let's be clear about the idea
rather than than the terms the idea is a
world of independent nations that's
that's what we're trying to describe and
the reason that I use National realism
is because that's that is actually the
traditional word for that ideology and
I'm I'm not that interested in altering
uh my vocabulary because of Hitler I
don't want to learn political Theory
from Hitler the word um a patriotism
it's a perfectly fine word but
patriotism means my love of my country
I'm a patriot I'm an English Patriots or
I'm an Israeli Patriot so patriotism is
is the love of your country but now we
move into Political Theory we're looking
for a general principle what what what
term do we use to describe the idea that
the world should consist is better off
if it is governed as a world of
independent nations the term patriotism
doesn't come close to capturing that and
nationalism simply does it it's just an
appropriate use of the term so since I
don't have another word yeah so I I so I
I I I use that word well actually first
came across your work in 2016 in the
wake of the brexit referendum very much
going against the what was the loud
typical and rather cliched uh response
to this or this is a racist movement
whatever and you went into the deep
biblical roots of naturalism which you
then uh went into further detail in your
books The Virtue of nationalism and that
for me was new information and I found
that very interesting actually
naturalism is an ancient Theory yeah I
wanted listeners who hadn't heard that
the biblical roots of it if you might
give a light introduction okay a late
introduction
um
first of all it's it is important to
take everything you learn in University
with a grain of salt and uh since World
War II there's been uh there's a a
discipline called that uh nationalism
and ethnicity studies uh you know which
which has a a few thousand members these
professors who are paid full-time to
think about the subject and the founders
of the discipline
um are uh almost all of them either uh
Marxist anti-nationalists or liberal
anti-nationalists so it's it it it's a
it's a discipline founded by
anti-nationalists and uh and they go
around telling people that look
nationalism was was invented uh during
the French Revolution uh or maybe they
push it back a little bit and say okay
it was invented in in Britain 100 years
earlier
um but uh there there is at this point
even in the universe cities there's a a
small but high quality
group of Scholars
who who've been looking to try to
understand where does the idea of an
independent nation as opposed to a
nation that's subservient to some Empire
where does that come from I need to go
back to the 12 Hebrew tribes of well it
it it's it's not me though there was a a
brilliant scholar named Adrian Hastings
who wrote a book already in the 1990s
called the construction of nationhood
his thesis is
look where where does the idea of an
independent nation appear and he claims
that throughout throughout Western
history and also outside of the West in
in uh in Africa and Asia he claims that
the the ideal of an independent nation
appears where the
um where the the Bible and specifically
the Old Testament when it's translated
into a local language that's where you
where where you see it appear and he
takes he he takes medieval France and he
takes Ethiopia looks at all sorts of
examples
um
there's pros and cons to this Theory but
let me give the light introduction that
you asked me for so
um
when you read the the Hebrew Bible the
Old Testament the background to the
story is that uh the great political
orders in in the time of the Bible
during the Thousand Years that are being
described in in the Old Testament
um the Egyptian Empire the Babylonian
Empire the Assyrian Empire the Persian
Empire
these are very very different
civilizations but what they have in
common is that in every single one of
them uh the God sends the king to
conquer the four corners of the earth
and why because that's what's going to
bring peace and prosperity now notice I
mean we usually think imperialism oh
it's just evil no actually I mean
there's a there there's a a strong
argument behind all of these Imperial
ideologies the the argument is if we can
eliminate the independence of all sorts
of small peoples we will eliminate war
and will will allow material prosperity
to flourish in the absence of wars that
come and destroy all the crops bring
famine and kill millions of people this
sounds like a defense of supra
nationalist States like the EU well you
know the funny the funny thing is that
this uh this ancient ideology is still
very much alive in the EU and the world
economic forum and the World Trade
Organization but in the Bible the the
remarkable thing about this is despite
the fact that that the imperialist
ideology that you know it has it has a
positive motivation it's not only about
uh uh raping and pillaging
um but despite that the the israelic
prophets the the prophets and Scholars
who wrote the Bible they they disagree
about many things but they're United in
their objection to human Empire they
they construct this idea of uh Israel is
an independent nation they celebrate uh
leaving in uh the departure from Egypt
and the Israelites the the the the the
the
12 tribes uniting under a single uh
under a single ruler they they celebrate
um this as being
um uh a a I don't want to say that it's
an ultimate political principle people
but it's a it's it's a central political
principle it's not it it's not and it's
not just for the Israelites the prophets
start start to tell you about uh other
nations and and uh and how Israel should
should suffer because of their loss of
Independence and they Envision a future
in which uh you know these famous lines
about uh the wolf lying down with the
with the lamb these fam these famous
lines are metaphorical description of a
world in which nations will stop trying
to be Imperial and and great Nations
will allow small Nations to chart their
own course so this is one of the central
political teachings of the Bible and it
is one that has inspired uh National
Independence movements uh throughout
history uh in including especially in uh
in England and in America so that is an
example of the Israeli people whoever
shared God who built a nation from that
but we're in Britain this is a
multi-ethnic state there's
multi-religious State as in America
multi-ethnic multi-religious can a
nation be a nation without a founding
binding religion underneath it I think
that the answer is is yes but it uh it
it's a little bit complicated we should
always look at Nations as a uh as a
collection of tribes
uh and that's not only because that
that's the way that the nation is
described in scripture but also in in
reality that there simply are no Nations
that that that that are internally
homogeneous all nations are uh are are
are are diverse so
um
you know if we go back to to just for a
second to founding moments
um the uh the the the first
um great attempt to establish an English
nation is uh is with Alfred and he's
uniting diverse tribes and uh uh the
same with the the Dutch and their
struggle for Independence the same with
uh the the Americans and the the the the
the the the great question in American
in in the American revolutionary period
the great question is in many ways the
same as the the biblical question is is
it possible for these for these 13 very
very different colonies with very very
different cultures these 13 states is it
possible to unite them as a single
nation now if you accept that all
nations are internally diverse to one
degree or another
then I think that the the the the
question of you know how do we do how do
we uh unite a modern a modern nation
which is uh internally diverse I think
the question it's it's a very important
question but I think it becomes less
um
it comes many people seem to feel that
it's just impossible that you know as
though we're facing for the first time
in history uh um the the the need to
bind
multiple ethnic groups or multiple
religions in a single nation I actually
think that this is an eternal problem
that it's an unending problem through
our throughout recorded history and
um and the the answer is going to be
somewhat different in each case all
right in in Israel we the people may not
know in Israel there's a uh there's a
small people called called the druze the
Drews are a a middle eastern people they
have their own religion uh it's not
Judaism it's not Islam it's not
Christianity it's some kind of an
interesting interesting fusion and
um so it's a a people with its own
identity that in in Israel we have a few
hundred thousand Drews and
um and from the founding of the state of
Israel uh this this uh Drew's people has
uh has been has been loyal to the the
state meaning
um that they said look we we want to
support Jewish Independence we're a
small people we're not going to try to
you know claim that that that we're
equals in size or in strength but will
serve in the military and uh and and
this relationship I don't want to say
that it's
um that it is uh uh you know without any
kind of tension all human relationships
have tension but it's been very
successful when Drew's military units
have ceremonies they fly the Drew's flag
next to the Israeli flag at the same
level this kind of experience of of
smaller peoples I I think you you can
find it almost everywhere the fact that
someone is a minority doesn't mean that
that they have to be excluded or abused
or that they will be disloyal well
perhaps a program is or it could be
better posed in that
there is a majority let's say in Israel
and they have there has been a majority
in America in Britain but in Britain we
are now a minority Christian country in
America it seems that the country is
splitting in two because they have
completely different conceptions of what
the the founding myth of the country the
founding story of the country and they
don't they can't agree on what that is
it's no longer about a majority that
binds in a a tolerated minority it seems
that there's a splitting up so I
wondered
there what that's a bigger problem right
that's a that's a different publisher
for sure because
we we all know that that Civil Wars are
are a real possibility in every nation
um preventing Civil War
always involves although people don't
like to talk about this but but avoiding
Civil War always involves having some
kind of a dominant group that is strong
enough on the one hand to say look our
our culture our Traditions they're going
to be the main traditions because of
that we can also bring in other groups
um I wouldn't even say necessarily uh
tolerating them it could be just an
alliance we can go into alliance with
other groups that will accept us as the
leadership but they'll have an honored
place with their own Traditions that are
that are different
the problem is exactly as you say that
that in the United States
we've seen that
be lost when I was in college those were
the Reagan Thatcher years no one in the
United States had the slightest doubt
that America was a nation no the
question didn't even arise you know
maybe some some uh radical Professor
would talk about it but everyone knew
that America was a was a nation
everybody knew that that historically
America was was uh
um uh was was an anglo-protestant nation
that had brought in a a large Catholic
minority and also Jews and others but
the the the historic character of The
American Nation was was not in doubt the
kind of questions that were asked was
how can how can we do justice to the
black minority it seems that the the the
they've suffered Injustice what do we do
about it but the question of America
being a nation was never a question uh
much has changed in part it's because
there's
um uh there's a very large proportion of
the population that are immigrants but
it but that's not really that's not
really the problem because you know
there have been other periods in
American history where 15 of the
population has been foreign born just
like today and and there were tensions
but you didn't feel like the country was
about to split into
do you feel that way do you think it is
a about to split into would you well
look I'm not I'm not going to make a uh
a crystal ball are you concerned about
the future of America yes absolutely
absolutely no no question at all the
degree of tension between a
woke Neo Marxist left
uh which is now that that may be a small
minority but but the way human politics
works is that a small minority if it's
if it's vocal enough and organized
enough it can dominate much larger
a much much larger political groupings
so I mean we should we should never
forget that that you know the the
Bolsheviks were never more than five
percent of the population in the Soviet
Union human populations are very very
often governed by a a small motivated
aggressive minority which one way
another seizes control and this is what
I'm describing is it's it is a dynamic
that it's not just a dynamic in you know
in a coup d'etat in dictatorships this
this is true in Democratic societies
also that if you have a a small highly
motivated ideologically coherent group
then their concerns are heard much more
loudly than the concerns of other people
and human beings naturally have a
tendency to say look well if they're so
loud then they must really care okay so
we're looking in America
um and you're more concerned with the
the progressive my small that small
group on the on the left rather than the
small group on the right is that a
concern of yours well look uh it it sort
of depends on who you're talking about
uh what's happening on the left is that
um that the the Democratic party which
used to be
um a a version of a liberal party uh you
know and institutions like uh uh like
the New York Times or Harvard University
uh those were kind of the the
ideological homes for the old liberalism
um that old liberalism look I have all
sorts of disagreements with that as a
conservative
um but but as a conservative for many
years growing up I had no problem
reading the New York Times I I knew that
I didn't agree with you know the slant
that they put on many stories but
they had conservative writers they they
thought conservatives were legitimate
and uh and you know the there were all
sorts of things that I could agree with
the old liberals on
um
uh that's gone it's disappeared uh it
2020 was a watershed year uh the year in
which
um The New York Times began firing
people for being old-school liberals the
the year in which uh Princeton I went to
Princeton Princeton University
um uh erased Woodrow Woodrow Wilson's uh
name from the from the school of uh from
the wood Wilson school and from Wilson
college that was a year of cultural
revolution and that cultural revolution
brought to power a non-liberal ideology
which took over the media the
University's Hollywood government
bureaucracy even the military your
defense of conservatism is one that it's
families and then communities perhaps
that's local communities but there's
very much the progressives would do it
with identities sexual identities uh an
ethnic groups even if they're not people
who are actually in a functioning
community together they will use the
words like the fallacy of the word
community that actually use it it's so I
sort of see a mirror and actually I
still get a bit of a I'm honest and
perhaps this makes me a liberal I get a
little bit triggered by the exploring
tribe I particularly don't like tribal
when it it's
ethnic groups on the right and and and
so there's a there's a kind of there's a
difficult side to both things that play
there for sure
um
look both
you're right there there's uh there
there is a certain commonality between
Marxist and conservative critiques of
liberalism
um and and in in my book I mean I I I I
like what I'm teaching to to try to get
the students first to understand what's
what the strengths of a of a point of
view is before I dive into saying what's
what's wrong with it because look
Marxism has to have it has you know very
often liberals and conservatives talk
about Marxism like it's one big lie
there's reasons for that but it but it
isn't really true because the the the
the strength of the Marxist worldview is
that it recognizes certain realities
that liberalism denies like well as you
said the Marxist worldview is based
first of all on identifying actual human
groups Marx calls them classes but
basically he's he's talking about human
groups that the fact that human beings
form cohesive groups and that those
groups compete and struggle against one
another and that sometimes they they
exploit and abuse one another that's
that's a reality that can take place in
Liberal society and liberals can can
really be blind to it because because
they're always talking about the
individual and they don't they're not
aware that it's possible even in
liberalism even in a democratic society
for human beings to form groups and to
abuse one another and so the the reason
that marxists have such a a powerful uh
uh holds that the the attraction to
Marxism of its different kinds of
Marxism is so powerful for young people
is because uh Marxist instructors they
say look the Liberals are lying to you
let me just look around you do you see
human beings being individual or do you
see human beings forming into groups
which abuse one another and and so the
the marxistent instructors that it you
know it feels to the students like
they're ripping the veil off of reality
and you you see the truth after
correctly recognizing that there that
there's always tension and struggle
among competing groups in every society
after they say that then they say well
look the dominant group the strongest
group is inevitably exploitative
uh their assumption is that every group
will always abuse and exploit every
other group if they get the chance and I
I think that's not true I think I think
there's an element of Truth absolutely
they're they're uh there is such a
tendency but it doesn't I but what I
don't accept is the the Marxist claim
that inevitably every uh dominant group
will exploit and oppress as much as it
can and B I don't accept that the only
answer to that is to destroy the ruling
class and that I mean that's classical
Marxism and that part of it is very
obvious in woke neo-marxism where
they're not talking about economic
classes right now now that that but but
the ruling class that they have in their
mind the you know the the uh the
straight white male and and you know his
fraternity and his patriarchy their goal
is to destroy that as a political
um as as a politically influential uh
element within Society so
the old Marxism is expressed in this
woke neo-marxism and then in the new
cancel culture and progressivism with
this goal that there's no possible
relationship between a dominant group
and the other groups other than
oppressor oppressed a conservative will
say come on
there's always a strongest group but
peace in society and Justice are
normally achieved through a kind of
negotiation through wise rulers that
understand that that the society will be
stronger and more cohesive if the
different groups are loyal to one
another and how do you get to that
loyalty well you get to that loyalty by
by trying to understand what the
different groups you know not every
single thing they want is something that
they can get but the the goal of a just
ruler of a just government is to try to
understand what's important to what's
most important to each group and see how
a balance can be attained now it's not
always possible sometimes there just has
to be struggle you know until one side
wins but the main goal of politics in my
view and this is you know this is where
I disagree with uh radical rightist
theorists uh Nazi theorists like like
Carl Schmidt will tell you no politics
is always about about who's your enemy
and and annihilating your enemy no
actually most politics most of the time
is about trying to uh navigate the
competition among groups in such a way
that everybody gets something of what
they want everybody is honored to a
certain degree at least and from that to
build a cohesive Society uh in in in
which you know there are no groups that
that feel that they've simply been uh
eliminated from the game completely in
Practical times you you say are
concerned about America how can that
Unity return
do you think I I don't I don't know if
it can I mean I I can I can tell you
what brings Unity
what brings Unity is
um is
honoring one another okay which is
something liberal political Theory
doesn't almost doesn't recognize but
it's Central in the Bible and it's
Central and conservative thought
um
you treat someone as a cause that they
have influence that they're not ignored
contemptuously but that somebody's
paying attention to them and if
something is of concern to them then it
then then it becomes a concern to others
you know you can you can still just get
the videos of Reagan Mondale or Reagan
Carter debates or go back to Kennedy
versus
um Nixon in the 1960s the entire posture
is you know is look my esteemed
colleague from the other side you know
the assumption is inherited from the UK
obviously the assumption is that the
opposition is loyal the assumption is
look our policies are better but if you
know if if my colleague wins the
election so of course we're going to
support him we're going to collaborate
and trying to do the best we can in this
country we'll we you know we'll we'll
disagree on on some things but on the
important things we're going to work
together that's the Assumption there's
this constant
um handing over of of uh gestures of uh
respect and even affection and good
humor and and that that creates a a very
real Bond of mutual loyalty when both
sides are doing that we can see in
America the terrible bitter pulling
apart which reminds us of the eve of the
American Civil War but what we don't
know is
um if we do the right thing if we do
what we ought to do
um whether you know whether we might not
be able to turn it around whether
God might not help us a little bit if we
um
uh if we make one one last effort to
hold it all together in your book uh
conservatism a rediscovery you there's
almost a I took it as a revisionist
history that actually the the second
world war the 20th century wasn't the
victory of
liberalism as much as it was the victory
of Christian liberal democracy as much
as it was Christian democracy
when you see let's say Hungary or Italy
and certain
religious conservative movements growing
again does that give you is that the
sort of Christian democracy you're sort
of imagining it yes
um
I don't believe that there is any Force
strong enough to Def to defeat woke
neo-marxism except for political
Christianity now I'm an orthodox Jew I
have plenty of uh issues with with
Christianity both in theory and in
practice
but when I uh look at this cultural
revolution that that we're going through
and and the way that you know
every couple of years that that pass
brings us to and even more aggressive
imposition of revolutionary ideas when I
say Revolution I mean that in the
negative sense tearing apart everything
that has been inherited that was any
good and not claiming everything we
inherit is good but tearing apart first
you know they began in the 1960s uh
first with with uh God in scripture and
then from there to the destruction of
the idea of nation and family and
finally they've gotten to the the the
elimination of the ideas of man and
woman and it look there there is no end
to this the this this
aggressive critique of every inherited
idea it it will destroy us first to
misery and then to weakness and then to
dictatorship this is the sort of point I
was trying to get at earlier is that
without an underlying majority religion
to bind yes a country a nation can that
really be a nation but so just on
political Christianity
what is political Christianity is that
theocracy every society has a majority
framework okay and as as look as a as a
Jew
um I I'm you know one of these groups
that kind of you know doesn't fully fit
into the the old dominant uh ideology or
worldview in America or in Britain but
those dominant ideologies the old
British Christian synthesis the old
American Christian synthesis
they were compared to you know compared
to uh historically to what what we've
known they were very generous to Jews
until all sorts of other minorities and
um and sometimes not so generous but
yeah sure no of course you know look it
would be easy for me to go into listing
the history of of things that I find
objectionable about the history of
Britain but what on Earth is the point
of this because if if if you're just
trying to say I don't care what happens
next let's just destroy the whole thing
so go right ahead just name everything
that was ever wrong with it but you know
usually when you tear the whole thing
down what comes afterwards is much much
worse okay and how many how many how
many examples of of that do we need I
mean the the the the the the whole
communist and Nazi and fascist project
of the 20th century was uproot and
Destroy whatever has come and we'll just
invent something we'll use you know
science or or some new philosophy in
order to invent everything from scratch
what good ever comes of that I mean
nothing no good comes out of those
revolutions if you want good you take if
you actually want good a conservative
will will say you you want to improve
things so take the existing inherited
order find don't don't tell me all about
how it can be redesigned find the one
thing that is Trump most Troublesome
from a perspective of justice and let's
repair that and see how that goes okay
that that's a conservative approach all
conservatives will agree that that what
you inherit is not perfect and that
repairs are necessary they all agree the
question is are we going to focus on
trying to fix one thing or do we listen
to these you know theorists about how
yes I can simply revise all of
civilization So my answer is no don't do
it the cultural revolution that's coming
there's no evidence that it works
there's not they don't even claim it's
going to work they only claim that
they're achieving Justice by destroying
so where do we have to go we're well we
don't we don't have a lot of choices
here Britain is uh is a country as you
said in which in which Christianity
really is a minority
um but I think that those of you who
like me are not Christians I think need
to ask themselves because this is this
is the choice we're not going back to
the old liberalism the old liberalism
was unable to defend itself against woke
neo-marxism it's unable to it's not
strong enough to do it in the end if you
want to back an order that is going to
be strong enough then you're going to
have to support some kind of an
accommodation with uh with the with the
old Christian framework that gave
stability to life the liberal theory of
separation of church and state
you know which is that's an American
Theory it's strange to impose it in in
Britain where there's you know a cross
on the flag and an established church
but I've I've come to understand that
that the that the um
the American liberal uh theory of
separation of church and state that it's
become very powerful it's become very
intuitive even here in the UK in America
what's it sort of seems to get ignored
is that even though there is a
separation philosophically the the the
foundational political texts are do have
religious presuppositions so the
referencing God a Creator and so
actually even though that
the political institutions are separated
from the from the church at the
foundation it is founded on the
religious worldview well that's true but
I I would take take it further the uh
the principle of separations of church
in the state enters American
constitutional law in 1947 after World
War II the you know so we we all kind of
live in this optical illusion in which
everyone somehow thinks that that
America had separation of church and
state since the founding of this there's
zero truth to it there's no truth to it
at all the the the the First Amendment
the purpose of the first amendment was
to allow the the church establishments
and the the different kinds of uh
religions in the different states to be
uh independent and not to be interfered
with by the Central American government
America was a Christian Nation and it
was recognized as a Christian Nation by
law or Christian people by the American
Supreme Court until the 1930s and so
what what we're dealing with is part of
the post-war liberal experiment is let's
let's see what happens if you take God
and Bible out of all of the schools in
the country by force you know all most
of the country has this or that kind of
relationship with Christianity
in 1948 the particular First Step that
the Supreme Court took in the United
States was that in 1948 in the
McCullough case Chicago schools here
here's here's what the Chicago schools
were doing they were allowing
um a Catholic priest a Protestant
Minister and a rabbi to enter the school
for certain times during the week and to
offer instruction
um in in the different religions and
students and their parents could choose
which which they would go to and and
they also allowed students to not go if
they you know if if there were a good
faith uh uh um descent that is what was
ruled unconstitutional by the U.S
Supreme Court 1948 is this marvelously
you know pluralist generous attempt to
allow students to learn something about
religion when that became
unconstitutional and then a few years
later Bible was banned that was the
first Domino yes and and look this is an
amazing thing that we're watching it's
it's literally 60 years two generations
from the time that Americans say okay
we're going to eliminate just eliminate
God in scripture from from the schools
will limit it to you know an hour a week
on Sunday from that moment until the you
know these
mind-numbing debates about you know
about
is this one a woman or is that one a
woman it's 60 years yeah and you you you
can't tell me that there's that there's
no causal relationship because the
because it's been proceeding in the in
in in a straight Vector for 60 years
when GK chest is makes me think of
Justin he said when people no longer
believe in God they don't believe in
nothing they believe in anything as the
months are passing woke new Marxism
takes on the trappings more and more of
of an organized religion and you know it
it will have its gods and it will have
its liturgy I mean it's going to be
Pagan it's not going to be Christian
I I just think people need to make a
choice I'm not telling people what to
believe I'm telling you that if you want
to save
your country but also if you if you want
to be able to build a stable family if
you want to be able to save yourself I
don't mean in the Christian sense I mean
in the in in the personal worldly sense
if you want to be able to save yourself
you you have to join communities that
are resisting this
it it's the only way to have a decent
life one thing I wanted to ask you which
is maybe a little bit of a left turn
here is
about you well you mentioned immigration
earlier in this conversation right at
the beginning of this conversation and
in Britain we are due or it's expected
that we'll have a million net migrants
into the UK this year uh which is double
last year and
um pre-brexit I think it was never more
than 330 000 at its peak
uh a conservative argument in favor of
that is that we have a
um population crisis in that we're
heading into population Decline and
economically it's good to have
immigrants to fill that
gap for the for the economic progress of
the of the country to sustain that aging
population and to make sure that there
is a critical mass of working people to
keep the the state together
are you in favor of that argument or
against that argument well I mean I'm
against the argument but I I also want
to try to push it out of the
conservative Zone I think it's a liberal
argument it's a liberal argument because
it
refuses to acknowledge that there is
such a thing there is such a thing as an
English nation and it it has a historic
character it has a certain culture of
course it's possible to absorb uh
immigrants so long as uh the the
immigrants are highly motivated to
become English to adopt English culture
and so long as the numbers are small
enough so that you know so that England
can actually uh bring them in in a
successful way okay so with the with the
birthing crisis assuming you agree with
me that there's a population crisis
maybe I shouldn't assume there's no
alternative for for a nation of people
that wants a future there's no
alternative to having children
and the the assumption that foreign
adults
can replace
um the the children raised in English
households
it it it's an absurd assumption I mean
I'm not saying that the the economic
measure doesn't have some kind of uh uh
value and truth to it the problem is
it's as is often the case with
liberalism it's this little partial
truth the the the the broader truth is
that that a a Britain that is not having
children has no future and these islands
will end up being they'll they'll end up
being taken over by some other country
at some point
if you you want to have a future you
can't avoid the basic responsibility of
of human beings to any society that they
love which is to bring children into
that society and to raise them with with
with its value and worldview but
something has happened in which people
are not having children yeah people
can't afford it
or they don't want it
what is the conservative response to
that is is it for government to support
families a government certainly has to
make sure that
first of all that
um financially that the incentive
structure is
um is
towards getting married staying married
and uh and having as many as as many
children as possible that's the uh and
that is the the way the incentive
structure should be built but human
beings are not primarily economic lots
of people in history have had many many
children when when they were poor and
and and also during the the after the
Industrial Revolution not only in on
farms
the the principal thing is to give honor
to marriage to traditional classical
marriage to to child raising also by the
way to serving in the military I mean
the these are things that if the
The prominent and the influential people
the leadership of the country if they
are not constantly giving or honor to
these things then then people will then
then you can't expect the society you
know to revolt against the entire the
entire Elite and the entire leadership
and say no no no no we're going to have
a different set of values that might
happen but I think I think people simply
underestimate the the uh the the
influence that I mean just just think
about how Donald Trump
reshaped the way that not just in
America that you know tens of millions
of people think in America and many
other countries or the the way that
Barack Obama did or or or or or or Bill
Clinton or Ronald Reagan Thatcher
people are shaped by their leaders to a
degree that we just don't want to admit
and our leaders are not there they're
scared they're scared to say
conservative things and so they're
scared to say something like you know
um getting getting married young is is
is better than putting it on you know
um uh having three or four children is
is better than having no children or one
child serving the military is better
staying married is better than getting
divorced every political leaders are
scared to say these utterly simple
things what do you think apart from that
of the other
key issues apart from the the population
decline that that we need to think about
or start putting our minds towards
um
you know in the political realm the the
bigger the biggest issues first first
national Independence you know
um
brexit isn't isn't actually done I mean
the the there is still a
um a resistance to uh allowing
um
parliamentary democracy in Britain to be
independent of all sorts of decisions
being made by all sorts of bodies in
other places so first of all national
Independence um and then
um I would say
uh
immigration
family and and uh and children and the
great cultural revolution those the the
the the woke Neo marxists that must be
with the wolf who whose aim is to to
take over the schools and use the
schools to convince everyone that that
you know that that uh that the old
family is is an instrument of of a white
male oppression and needs to be
destroyed yeah
so my last question what's the future of
the National Conservation okay look at
the national conservatism is somewhat
it's somewhat of redundant term because
the the nation is always important to
all conservatives but um but it's
appropriate at this moment to use it as
as a as a slogan as a symbol because it
makes it clear we're not talking about
the old the the so-called conservatives
who are trying to uh create one world
liberal order we want independence for
our nation we want to restore
um a beneficial National Traditions
certainly at the level of the family but
probably probably at other levels as
well
um and this is you know it's interesting
that I I said conservatism is different
in in every country but the the the the
objection to Liberal internationalism to
to the new world order that objection is
very similar in you know all sorts of
countries so you you can you can you
have Catholic majority countries and
post-christian countries and uh and
Israel is a Jewish State and India is a
Hindu State and the effort to resist the
imposition of this globalist fantasy
which will be a globalist nightmare you
know that opposition actually it creates
an interesting uh Alliance of different
different peoples in different nations
what a pleasure to um to have National
conservatism appear in Britain it's this
historic home for
um for much of what we value in western
civilization we're all cheering for you
and and um it's it's deeply meaningful
not just for you but for the rest of us
well Dr hazoni thank you for taking the
time to speak with me
[Music]
foreign